In this video,
we actually see how we can perform
sequence classification in a linear chain
conditional random fields.
So,
so far what we've seen is how we could
compute the probability, the churn,
probability of a whole a sequence
of labels given an input sequence.
Uh,
so we've seen how we could compute in
particular this nasty partition function
using dynamic programming.
Okay.
And we are also seeing how
we could compute marginal
probabilities. For instance,
the marginal probabilities of
a label like a given position.
K given the full sequence and again,
performing this computation required
the same dynamic program, uh,
that uh, uh, we can use for
computing the partition function,
what would compute these log alpha and
lug better tables and use them in the
computation of the marginal probability.
Yeah.
Now here what we'll see is how we
can actually perform classification.
So if I give you a sequence of
inputs now I ask you to, uh,
provide with,
provide me a sequence of labels that
you think is a good prediction for the
sequence of, uh, the, the actual
true sequence of labels, uh, that,
uh, that a human or an
expert would have predicted.
So, um, Darra two options here.
So we'll see two different procedures for
performing that prediction. The first,
uh, is perhaps those simplest, uh,
what we do is that for each position,
Kay,
we compute the marginal p
of y k given the sequence.
So we compute the probability
for any potential label,
why k of it being the true
key if label in the sequence.
And then as our prediction,
we just say that, uh,
in our predicted sequence, the label
for the prediction, uh, the key,
if the position is going to beat the
label that has the highest marginal
probability.
Now I'm,
so this is very similar to
how for a neural network, uh,
that would take just a single input. So
none in the sequence prediction sending,
we would just feed the input to
the neural net. It would produce a,
a output distribution,
uh,
for what the true label
would be for the given input.
And we just take the label
with the highest probability
and now we can actually
show that this procedure for
constructing a prediction sequence.
So a sequence of labels that we
would provide us an answer, uh, is,
uh,
corresponds to the prediction that
minimizes the sum of classification errors
over the whole sequence if we assume that
our linear conditional random fields.
So our model is actually the true model
is the true distribution that produced
the a sequenced labels in our
dataset. So we actually, uh,
this gives some justification for
using that procedure. And, uh,
uh,
because this is an interesting concept,
I actually will actually do the
demonstration for why maximizing for each
position,
the marginal distribution actually
corresponds to finding this, uh,
minimizing sequence of the,
some of classification there.
If we assume our model is
the treat distribution.
So what do we want to do is,
uh,
find the expression for what
is the predicted sequence?
Why start that minimizes in expectations.
So I should say this is the
minimization in expectation.
According to our model of the,
some of the classification there are for
each position. So where you have these,
some of the identity function of whether
the true label according to our model,
why Cain soars to label in the
sense that it's the label that uh,
based on, uh, uh,
the distribution of our model is different
from the predicted label at position
Kate.
So why star Kay?
So we want to minimize in expectation
that some of castigation there per
position.
So here I'm just writing explicitly
what this expectation here is.
It's the nested some over the first
a label up to the last label of the,
some of Perella a preposition
classification error
weighted by the probability
according to my model that I would
observe this sequence of labels a y.
So these white case here,
yeah,
I'm running the fact that the
minimization over all sequences,
why star is equivalent,
so perform that immunization is the
same as performing minimization, uh, uh,
sequentially over the first
label until the last label.
So it's this minimization over all
sequences is the same as these nested
minimization over first seek
first, uh, uh, position.
Second position until the last position.
Now here in what I'm doing is that
I'm going to take that, uh, first,
I'm going to introduce this here,
uh,
which allows me to just
remove this parent. This is,
and I'm going to change
the order of the songs.
So I'm going to actually some first over
the position k and then some over the
value of the first label up to the last
label. So that's why I have key here.
Then first label up to the
last label. Okay. So, uh, that,
that's all I've done,
introduced this here and change the
order of the sums up the nest itself.
Now,
uh,
I noticed that this term here only
depends on the value of a y k for the
position k that's indexed here.
So I can actually,
this is a constant with
respect to y one Y K minus one.
Why k plus one up two.
So there should be three dots
here up to the last label.
So I can actually push this here,
uh,
up upwards in the nested sums,
writes in from the,
the sum over the value of
the Keith label. And the, uh,
sequence position gay ass,
which I'm measuring the error.
Okay,
next. I know this, that
this expression here,
that's just the marginal p
of y k given this sequence.
So I'm taking the full joint distribution,
well conditioned on the input sequence,
the joint distribution over
the whole sequence. Why?
But I'm summing over all the values
that every label can tech take.
Accept the label.
Why King?
So that's the marginal p of y given X.
Next, I, uh,
realized that this sum here over all
position of what is essentially the
expected error for that position.
Uh,
well that's essentially the sum of the
sum over why one of whether I'm making in
there or by predicting why star one
times weighted by the probability of
actually seeing why one as the
first label plus a. So I do this,
the sum over all, uh, case. So then, uh,
sum up to the sum over y capital gay,
uh,
of whether I'm making an error
by predicting why prime at,
why star capital gay weighted by the
probability that the true Labor would
actually be, why capital gain. Now, uh,
so I have a son and a minimizing
over this sum for each label. Well,
because each term in the, some actually
it depends on this single label.
Well that's the same as minimizing the
first terms are with respect to why a one
then actually, sorry, why
star one only. And uh,
and I don't need to minimize over the
other terms because they're not involved
in that expression plus the minimization
with respect to why start to up to the,
uh,
so plus up to the minimization over
the last label of this term here.
Okay.
So that's because the minimization over
all labels for a term that depends on,
on the one label is the same
as minimum as a minimum,
minimizing over a single
position or a single label.
And so, uh, now the, uh, uh,
we noticed that you mean remove some ink.
So we know this,
that this expression here,
which is the sum of a one,
if why one is not,
why star one weighted that by the
probability of observing why one uh,
so that's the sum of the property of
why one for every case, except when,
why one is equal to y star one.
So in other words,
so that's the probability of the
first label not being why star one,
which is equal to one minus
the probability of the
label of being why star one.
And so similarly for this term we also
get one minus the probability of y Star
capital k
and then find a need
performing each minimization,
minimizing one minus this storm is the
same as doing one minus the maximum of
disturbed.
So indeed this is a constant,
so I can't minimize it really the the
choice of why star one won't change the
value of one.
And so I can introduce this here and
the minimization of the negative of
something is the same as minus the
maximization of that's something.
So that's what I have here.
So this is equivalent to this.
And in particular the Arg,
Matt,
the argument here or the
Arg Max is the Arg Max here.
And in other words,
it's the a sequence where the first label
is the one that maximizes the marginal
probability for the first
element in the sequence.
And then same thing for the second level,
third level up to the last label,
which in my prediction should
be the label, why star gay,
which maximizes the marginal
probability of the, uh,
of the, uh, label at the last position
at the position capital came. Okay.
So this ends our demonstration
that if I assume the true, uh,
labels were generated by my model,
my linear, conditional random fields,
then if I wanted to minimize
the expected classification,
there are per position,
uh,
the right thing to do would actually to
be to produce a sequence of all labels
that maximize the probability of being
observed according to my model for each
position and concern
constructing my prediction by
concatenating all of these uh,
sequence, uh, all of these labels.
Okay.
So that's the first option.
And other option would be
to do the equivalent of what
we were doing in the non
sequential,
uh,
prediction part that is I'll just
produce as my sequence output.
The, uh, so actually this
should be a star here.
I'll actually just produce
as the sequence output,
the single sequence with the largest,
probably the largest joint probability
condition on my input sequence.
And so I'll go rapidly over this,
but it turns out that much like
we've seen a way of actually summing,
uh, uh, over the, uh, something
like this stone, the exponential,
uh, an annex exponentiate it,
uh, some of, uh, lug factors.
We can also perform the maximization with
the dynamic program. Uh, so we'll do,
uh,
we get essentially as a baritone guitar
be decoding where in the Ford pass so
much like in the Alpha, uh,
dynamic programming where we,
for the log Alpha, we had
luck, some ex operations,
well in the this bitter
be decoding algorithm,
we replaced those by the maximization
with respect to why prime canes.
That and then we fill the table
with those values. And, uh, in fact,
if you think about it,
luck,
some x is actually can be thought of
as a smooth version of the maximisation
operation.
And that's because,
because of the exponential exponential
here, the term diet is going to dominate.
This sum is going to be the term that
is largest because the exponential
increases very rapidly with
large values of its argument.
And then taking the log,
we go back to the original scale.
And so really the term that's going to
dominate this whole term here is going to
be the maximum. So, uh,
so that's just, you know,
a nice fact to know about the
relationship between the lugs,
Amex and the maximization.
Yeah.
And uh, but so yeah, so we take
the Ford Pass, say in the, uh,
diamond program that confuses the Lug
Alpha table and would you replace the Lug,
some x operations by a maximization
and then in the backward,
then we have to produce it backward pass.
And in the backward fast, well, we start,
we'll essentially compose are decoded.
Uh,
so I predicted sequence by finding the
last label that maximizes the value in
our table.
And then falling backward,
the trace of the Max operations.
So falling backward,
the links that are going to correspond
to what were the Arg Max when I was
performing this maximisation here.
So more specifically,
let's look at the pseudo code
for this, uh, algorithm. We, uh,
first initialized the
value of my Alpha stars.
I'm going to use star
for the dynamic program,
the Viterbi decoding algorithm that is
going to fill this alpha start table as
opposed to the Alpha table.
And notice that here we
have in maximization instead
of a Loxa Mex operation
where we do a maximization over what
would be the argument of the Loxa Mex
operation in the computation
of the log Alpha table.
So initialize the first column of my
Alpha Star table by performing this
maximization.
And I also remember for
each value of y star, uh,
sorry,
why prime too?
What was the actual value of y prime
one that was maximum is maximizing the,
some of the luck factors. So see
here, this is the same thing as here.
So this is just the Arg
Max of this maximisation.
Okay.
And then much like in the log Alpha table,
I'll go from the first,
from k equals two to the
last till the last column.
And then for each value of the label,
I'll perform the similar
similar computation where
I've the Luxor Max by the
maximization.
And here I have you in urinary refactor
or ice factor and the Alpha Star.
So the value at my previous
column in my Alpha Star Table.
And similarly I'll remember
what is the Arg Max.
So I'll put that into this other table,
which I'm uh,
where I put the Arrow to distinguish
it from the Alpha star table.
And then finally,
if I want to know what's the
probability of the most likely sequence,
why star?
So what's the maximum of why start
off of this should be a why star also?
Well,
it's just,
it just corresponds to taking the
maximum over this expression here.
Okay.
And uh, so that's, uh,
actually not exactly taking,
I said the taking the Max over the last
column, but that's not exactly true.
It's the Max over the last column plus
the urinary luck factor for the last
position.
Yeah.
And then to perform decoding that is to
actually construct my predicted sequence.
Why Star? I'll take the,
again, the Arg Max of Dicks.
This maximisation here.
So the Arg Max of the urinary factor
at the last position plus the y at the
Alpha Star, uh, for the last
column of my Alpha Star Table.
So that's going to be the predicted
label for the last position.
And then I'll go backwards
from the previous, the last
position till the first.
And what I'll do is that why star gay,
it's just going to be
what was the, uh, Arg Max.
So you see the Arrow here
was what was the Arg Max, uh,
when I performed the
maximisation for Alpha Star Gay,
assuming that the value for y star
keep last one for y prime plus one is
actually why star keep us one,
which is the value.
Why star in my sequence that I
computed in a previous iteration.
So we see that by initializing,
why star capital key here? Well,
I always have the value for that.
So I'm going from right to left using my
proven Swi star value to construct my,
uh, uh, sorry. I guess the, the,
the value of why star at the position,
uh,
to the right took a constructor,
my prediction for the position,
the current position. Okay. And
then going from right to left. Okay.
So this is how I get a,
this is an algorithm,
but that is also a, that
has, you know, a nice,
a complexity of a that's polynomial in k
and a capital gain and capital c four a
computing, uh, constructing
your prediction.
And so classify a whole sequence of
inputs and producing a sequence of labels
for my sequence of inputs.
So the two types of predictions,
this Viterbi decoding approach and the
other one that maximizers the purpose,
mission marginal are two valid,
uh, predictions to perform.
If we really care about the
sum of the, some of the, uh,
per element, uh, do some of per
element classification errors.
We might want to prefer the
first procedure, but if instead,
our prediction a,
an error,
if the way we evaluate the
performance of our classification,
a sequenced classification
system is different.
And so for different systems,
I can speech, for instance,
we'd be more interested in a phone error
rates, which is more complicated than,
uh, performing. Uh, this Vittoria
be decoding procedure is a,
should be preferred because then we're
not maximizing the sum of per, uh,
position, uh, per position, uh, errors.